chennai is underwater again for the
second time in six years
the intensity and frequency of monsoons
is part of our changing climate
as india faces its impacts thousands of
miles away the world is running out of
time to stop it if you look at the
consequences of going higher in terms of
what's going to happen to countries
around the world extreme weather events
sea rising you know island
nations that are really
in trouble some of them now
so 1.5 has to be the target
is it achievable yes but it's tough but
action so far hasn't been enough we now
have the first analysis of how much of a
difference last week's major
announcements at cop26 will make pledges
from phasing out coal to cutting methane
and saving forests
the whole purpose of this summit is to
limit global warming to one and a half
degrees centigrade by the end of the
century but because we might get to that
point as early as the 2030s this
analysis looked at 20 30 pledges
combined they take us well beyond one
and a half degrees of warming to 2.4
degrees by the end of the century
and even in a really optimistic scenario
which includes very shaky pledges like
ending deforestation we still get to 1.8
degrees of warming by 2100
on one level it's great progress we were
facing three degrees of warming earlier
this year but it's shattering cop 26
president alok sharma's bid to keep 1.5
alive
can you tell us in concrete terms what
has to happen in the next few days
to make sure this isn't the summit where
1.5 dies
we are of course very clearly focused on
ensuring that we are keeping 1.5 within
reach where we get to is going to emerge
through consensus uh you know we'll have
the cover decision going out overnight
and i'm sure there'll be questions on
that as well during the press conference
tomorrow the cover decision is the
negotiating document that marks the
beginning of the end game here
outside the demonstrations continued
live to the reality there are now just
three days left to agree the plan to
save the planet
they chose an obvious but entirely
accurate metaphor
if these talks fail we all go down
together whether you're in china chennai
or the chile clyde
tom clark sky news glasgow